grasset
[Musique]
à l'oreille
il serait bien sûr face goody était face
à la caméra
vous avez des t-shirts numérotées vous
allez avoir c'est celui qui va réussir à
déchirer ses t-shirts le plus rapidement
possible et à se retrouver torse nu le
premier qui aura gagné qui sera le
meilleur oeil vous connaissez eu le
déclic énervé il déchire les habits
gilles en tout cas sa vraie énergie
ça vous va très bien vous êtes énervé il
n'est pas hervé millet lourd surtout un
riad
je vous le demande comme un service
gagnant gagnant
attention c'est parti top
[Applaudissements]
celle attendue
de scapin voilà
[Applaudissements]
calmez vous
attention reviendra pas
c'est parti
c'est ma vie
[Applaudissements]
attendez attendez mais je serai juste
montrer y est ouvert à la bce
c'est impossible il ya des lui ses
propres
voilà très clair on voit le saigner 17h
alors attendez roberts
on va vous parler de nation encore on
m'a vite et dur mais ces attentions
aller allons-y
c'est parti voilà merci attention c'est
reparti quinze à dix sept vigiles
alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
tu vas crever
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas possible
non
voilà on a on a failli perdre gilles
verdez applaudissements pour ayad
[Applaudissements]
alors à vos amis vient comme ça à torse
nu il s'en fout il a l'habitude à fond
des faits c'est aussi donc c'est vrai
l'enrichir et ryan façon six mois
qu'avait son corps serait torse nu
maintenant les mecs l'était il ya des
mecs sans rigoler ils sont torse nu
toute la journée cédant même le soir au
restaurant et dans l'absolu giga et
ouais on omet schmith faire au moins tu
reçois on joue dans la même catégorie
que tu vas nous tout l'été en fait on
essaie de se cacher ou savez derrière
les armes
ouais mais j'aimerais vers 19 heures moi
je veux mettre à des dossards ya des
dossards n'avait pas retenu ouais je
plaque pas venir moi parce que j'ai peur
qu'on leur ait été c'est une poudre ou
moins j'ai pas l'air comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]